would you rather have to tell your mom
everything you've ever done or have to
show her your porn history whoo
I would rather tell her everything I've
done
because I like making people
uncomfortable
so I would make sure we sat down on the
table
and I would make sure I maintained eye
contact and I would take her step by
step in history has done her maker
really worried for me as a human being
do you know what I mean like just my
Google search
can I tell you my son's friend was at
the house
and they were using my computer
and they hit the Google search and I
clear when I think I've done like weird
stuff
but I hear Jacob go Dad
why were you googling zebra diarrhea
yeah I'm like ah don't worry about it
buddy you know what I mean yeah
it's just uh yeah I'm so sorry